now we're going to introduce our keynote
speaker someone very special in the Pata
Community uh she was uh program chair in
back in 2018 and now we're going to
welcome her back as our keynote speaker
so let's give around a very warm welcome
to Dr Michelle Gil she is from uh Nvidia
and also technical lead at
bomio which is a uh Discovery platform
for pharmaceutical drug
Discovery so everyone give a very very
warm
just going to do a quick shift
here so thank you everyone um for the
warm welcome it's great to be here um
thank you to the organizers for the
opportunity to present um and thanks
everyone Friday morning sometimes I know
that can be rough um so thanks for
making it um so fun fact my first P data
was P data 2013 so exactly 10 years ago
today almost to like the very day I was
sitting in in these seats and I I don't
want to sort of spoiled the later part
of the talk I'll talk a little bit about
that um but that was pretty integral to
my decision to move from science into
into data science so cheers to to P data
for that um it was also really fun the
schedule's still online from 2013 so I
was browsing the uh the sessions and I I
realized that I remembered that I met
one of my very good friends to this day
at hia 2013 and it was also fun to note
the topics and the titles of of the of
the sessions because the field has
changed and evolved a lot since then so
it was a pretty cool trip um down memory
lane to do that so thought I would leave
you with that to start um so today I'm
going to talk about a couple of things
um broadly speaking some science some
machine learning um some some lessons
I've learned along the way maybe the
Hard Way um sometimes the easy way but
um hopefully it's there's something here
that speaks to to you um and I certainly
hope to see everyone at the fireside
chat i' I'd love to talk more
so a little motivation um for for why I
do what I do why the team does um what
we do drug development is an incredibly
long and expensive process um greater
than 10 years uh $2 billion to bring a
drug to Market and this is small
molecule uh numbers by the way for sort
of traditional drugs if you will um and
with the inflation who knows it's
probably even more these days I didn't
factor that in so these are numbers of
pre-inflation um today what we're going
to talk about is the early stage of of
drug Discovery um and how we can apply
artificial intelligence to it so that
stage involves things like selecting a
Target so what sort of enzyme is uh
malfunctioning in this disease that's
that's what we want to Target um and
then finding a drug or a precursor to a
drug that might bind that so that's a
lead so we we I identify a Target we
find a lead and then we have to spend a
lot of time optimizing that lead to um
improve its properties to make it more
select for the Target where we want it
to bind versus not binding the targets
where we the other proteins where we
don't want it to bind um we also want to
optimize um the the solubility we want
to uh prevent it from having other toxic
side effects so it's it's a very long
uous process so that just was to give
you a little flavor of sort of where uh
the the Deep learning artificial
intelligence work that that the team
does fits
in uh we use a lot of language models I
heard you like language models
I'm sure you I'm sure this isn't the
first language we talk I think I think
there's at least two or two others that
I thought would have them um so they are
revolutionizing uh drug Discovery also
um it turns out that not only are they
great for representing scientific the
text and and pulling information from
scientific literature um bi language is
a natural way to represent biology um
probably because that's how we
communicate so we as humans derived ways
to represent biology with language DNA
sequences string of four letters
concatenated together protein sequences
20 amino acids concatenated together um
small molecules we represent them with
their own language which I'll talk about
uh very briefly later on it's a very
natural way to to express science um so
we can use these language models to
extract information from the literature
so name dentity recognition uh
relationship inference relationship
extraction and inference this drug binds
to this target um it might be associated
with this disease things like scientific
knowledge graphs um chemical reactions
so when you design and optimize a drug a
chemist has to synthesize um that drug
it doesn't usually exist you know off
off the shelf that you might order so uh
to tell a chemist you know what's the
most efficient way to create this this
desired molecule that can be represented
with text um we can use uh these
language models to predict properties
things like toxicity solubility um
thermal thermal stability of a protein
um and then finally structure prediction
um I'll talk a little bit about it
shortly but biological moities they can
be represented with text but they're
threedimensional like they exist in
three dimensions and space truly does
matter for biology so I'll talk a little
bit more about that transition from how
you represent um the things that you
want to do and that you want to study so
uh set set up my next slide well um so
proteins um we're going to talk a lot
about those today uh they can exist as
amino acids so you can see the string of
amino acids um on the left those amino
acids fold up in various ways and so you
can see again on the left uh the the
sheets and the coils those are called
secondary structure that arranges itself
into a 3dimensional shape that we call
the pro we call protein so and that
problem is called the protein folding
problem
it is one of the brand challenges in
biology every year there are
competitions to do this it is one of the
hardest problems that that is known to
exist in biology so just keep that in
mind um for some of the later uh things
that I'll share with you um we can use
uh deep learning models to predict
structure so to predict uh
three-dimensional contacts what amino
acid is close to the other one in
threedimensional space we can do things
like that um we can generate sequences
so so you can say here's an enzyme that
um binds to I don't know Carbon entities
find me one that breaks down plastic
it's similar in sequences so you can
actually modify change design protein
function using languages but you can
also do it in three dimensions so where
you choose to do that really depends on
the situation and the type of data um
you can switch back and forth between
language and three dimensions so there's
all kinds of deep learning models um
that some of them have language models
some of these models use other types um
of
architectures so a brief outline of what
I'll talk about today um I'll give you
an overview of uh what what the team
does um it's a project called bioo um
it's I'll explain where the name comes
from but um we make lots of fish jokes
on the on the team so there there will
be some there will be a fish reference
later so just laugh when you get
it um bimo is both an inference service
and a framework for training so I'll
talk a little bit about those um and
sort of how we built them why we built
them who they're for um I'll talk about
a little bit of research that my team
does with a language model um this one's
called mle MIM so we're also all about
the portmantos so mole is molecule bio
is biology um so this is a small
molecule uh language model so it's for
generation of of Novel molecules and
then I'll talk a little bit about my
career progression and sort of lessons
uh from the
field so B I said has two parts to it um
there is a framework and the framework
is really focused on training models um
processing the data you can potentially
find tun the models um many large
language models are very expensive to to
train to pre-train so you know who wants
to do that if you don't have to um so
you can fine-tune them you can uh set
them up for some sort of Downstream task
that you want to predict um something
and then you can deploy them um there is
not a straight connection yet to our
inference service um but eventually
someday there will be an easy way to
literally deploy the models to the cloud
um we also have this inference service
um and it is for those who don't want to
set up and host their own models um
there's an API it is all the models are
validated we accelerate them with all
the goodness that Nvidia does to
accelerate things um and and so you hit
an API and you can get a prediction um
it's it's really that simple so many
cases these models take multiple gpus
they are you know difficult challenging
um this is a way that that that uh those
challenges were taken care
of um true to Pi data um there's lots of
python goodness and how you might
interact um with the inference service
so we have lots of uh we have a nice UI
um there's lots of Jupiter notebooks
that show U examples of workflows um
there's python client API so all of all
of the good things that you would want
as a data
scientist um I thought I'd show you some
pretty uh pretty U ice screens um so
I've never this was my first C fo in
being part of a team that develops a
project with the UI so it was fun um it
was it was really fun so this is sort of
our Landing screen we have a variety of
models for different scientific purposes
um a couple of these models were
developed by us many of them are from
researchers in the community so they're
not just things that we've done in house
um we want it to be you know sort of a
collection of important and useful
functionality so not not just idia
models um here's an example again
talking hearkening back to proteins um
this is a a structure prediction model
um it's called open fold you might have
heard of it um there's another one you
might have heard of called alol um
that's closely related um so you can put
in a protein sequence on the left and
then it will give you a structure you
can do all kinds of cool things with the
the display of the structure um painted
different colors rotate um and then then
sa the picture you can get and you can
get the threedimensional structure
downloaded um every functionality you do
in the UI will automatically generate uh
either uh corl or python code so that
you don't have to write your own
API similarly this is with generating
molecules so we'll talk a little bit
about this again later um it's a
language model and it will generate
molecules with certain
properties lastly um one of the
challenges in in drug Discovery is
figuring out if a molecule will fit
inside the pocket that's sort of the
name of the Target and this is a model
called it's a diffusion model called
diff dock it will dock the LI in the
pocket of the protein for you so you can
determine how well it fits if it's
likely to fit or
not so next is the framework and this is
actually where my team um spends a lot
of lot of our time um our team tends my
team tends to have sort of some sort of
scientific domain main expertise plus
deep learning um so this is really what
you might expect from a a deep learning
framework it's for it'll process things
it'll train models for you um because
we're Nvidia and we really want you to
use gpus it is it's multi-gpu multide
training is all enabled out of the box
um there's data parallelism there's
three different types of model
parallelism um currently we are pretty
llm focused but we are working on um
some other types of models if you're
familiar with um structure prediction
models we're working on some equivariant
models so open fold being being one of
them that some point we'll we'll have
coming um I guess one other thing oh
I'll I'll go over the name actually in a
bit so um this is sort of our what our
software stack looks like um and it's
based on Nvidia an Nvidia Project called
Nemo which is neurom modules so that's
where the name comes not actually after
the fish um it is language models it is
speech to text it's a whole variety of
uh sequence to sequence type type models
um and it it really gives us a lot of
the functionality that I just described
to you the model parallelism the
multi-gpu functionality comes from neemo
for the most part so that helped us when
we were a very small team trying to jump
start the development of of this product
um there's automated deployment with
python we're working on it um and really
I think one um you can see there's a lot
of green in this software stat um and
how it connects to gpus all the way at
the top to models so one of the key um
reasons Nvidia sits at the various
levels of the software stack is to
surface the best of Nvidia technology
all the way through the top um but but
there is this is a cyclic relationship
and I many customers don't always
realize that many users don't realize
that the demand from these types of
models that we develop helps to drive
and develop Nvidia technology
so with language models there is already
a lot of optimizations in the types of
gpus that we have for example the a100
gpus have very specific optimizations
for the types of attention mechanisms
that are calculated with language models
um you can imagine maybe in the future
if we're if we're really successful um I
think sort of the ultimate Flex at
Nvidia is if you can get the hardware
team to incorporate optimizations for
for your for your stuff so down the road
if equivariant models like fold and open
fold become a big deal maybe we can get
Hardware to be optimized for it so
that's sort of the the ultimate goal at
Nvidia Tri
time so next is a little bit of research
that my team has um goes through at
Nvidia um so this is one model language
model so hopefully more language models
um that we
developed um just to remind you this is
this is where we're sitting MIM is
really focused on the lead optimization
stage of drug discovery
um so that that process is something
like 3 years long so you find an initial
compound that binds and then you have to
optimize it um you make little changes
to it you a chemist will synthesize it
then you run some sort of assay um and
then you analyze the results you tweak
it again tweak it again and again and
again and again and that's how you end
up with a canidate drug um something
that where you've tried to design away
um all of the bad things and then
optimize for all of the good things that
process um it's called dmta design make
test analyze it's something like 4 to 6
weeks per cycle the that total is is
around 3 years and as you can imagine I
tried to allude to it's a very uh it's a
very repetitive process and processes
like that can be very well suited for
optimization with machine learning right
so imagine if we can do some of this in
silico um instead of having to to
produce these molecules and test them um
in the lab that would be a huge Boon
towards Str Discovery um another reason
that this is a a really nice area
there's lots of data available on on the
types of small molecules that you would
be using for for drug
Discovery so a quick sort of overview um
I realized there's a variety of
backgrounds here so a little bit of a
level set um with MIM I'm going to talk
about Auto encoders and then um a family
of models called variational Auto
encoders so autoencoders are really like
PCA or compression you take an input
voyy be it an image be it a sequence you
develop a numerical compressed
representation of it um and then you
attempt to recover it and so that's how
you train your model by how well it
recovers what you put into it there's
some tweaks that you can make but that's
the gist you can do this with images you
can do this with sequences um usually
for sequences it's called the seek
toseek model um that's great um
sometimes you might want to generate
like if I give it a cat can it generate
a lion or something like that um so
those types of the autoencoder models
aren't well suited to that um what is
often used is something called
variational Auto encoder functionally
it's very similar however um this latent
space that's in the center of of the
model we represent it as a distribution
um most commonly it's a gaan
distribution so the parameters for that
gaan distribution are also trained as
part of um a this model's training so
thus we have sort of a model of what
this Laten space looks like we can
sample it we can explore it um we can
try to generate new
things um so there's a variety of tasks
that you can do um with chem informatics
which is CH informatics sort of just
generally means small molecule work um
you can take a molecule take the
representation from the encoder and uh
put a property prediction model on it so
you can train that train that little bit
of that property prediction model then
you've got something very powerful for
predicting um I don't know solubility um
you can do sequence translation um a
common thing that's done there is uh
using text representations for a
molecule you can get a text
representation for a reaction so sort of
like if you're translating from English
to French um you can do molecule to
reaction um for Generation which
generation will require um some sort of
model like a vae um you can you know uh
put a molecule through the encoder and
then you can sample the lat space and
decode
it um so how do we represent molecules
with text um there's something called
Smiles um and it is there are rules for
how Smiles work um it stands for
simplified molecular line input system
um but it is a very common and compact
way of representing
molecules um you know that that's that's
it like again you can represent so much
of biology and science with with
text so the first model that we
developed um was called Mega moart so
again with the the portmantos um it's
big I guess molecules it's a Bart model
um if you're familiar with NLP it is
very very straightforward um uh seek
toseek model so there's no variational
bits inside of it um it's really good
for incoming things um it's not well
suited for Generation tasks and we
wanted that we wanted a model that also
could do generation
um so that is what led us on this
endeavor to develop a new
model um again Auto encoders so what
I'll talk about now is closer to a
variational auto
coder um and so that model became MIM um
we did what all good data scientists do
for this which is beg borrow and steal
existing stuff from the literature and
model architectures you avoid doing your
own if at all possible so in this case
um we it's called a perceiver encoder
it's a very special type of encoder um
developed by by Google um that will have
a fixed size Laten space um and I should
have removed this it's not yet organized
we we added a few tricks on it to
organize the Laten space um but we
trained it to do sequence translation
with
smiles um the way we organize the Laten
space is a little bit different than
what I described for a variational auto
encoder we trained it with something
called Mutual information machine you
you can just think of it as a derivative
of that um the reason we we didn't
choose vae a variational auto encoder
type uh model it tends to blur things so
you can see the clusters of the latent
space on the Clusters are by groups
whereas MIM tends to separate things in
nice um specific clusters so it groups
like together very well for
you um and we there's quantitative ways
to um prove that the molecules are
clustered but I thought it would be a
little more interesting um just to cover
a a qualitative way in which um the
molecules uh were tested so you can see
very small perturbations um there is
just a change in the way this hydrogen
atom is positioned so very very very
tiny things um that's called Regio
selectivity um larger molecules um if
you do bigger spaces bigger jumps they
start to become more different from each
other so um you can move further in lat
and space um than than you might desire
and one thing I should also mention um
though with MIM these clusters are like
is grouped with light the Clusters
aren't necessarily in any specific
representation to each other so you
don't really know there's no guarantee
that if you want this feature and you go
that way to the other cluster you'll
find it you don't really know so they're
grouped together but there's but beyond
that you don't really know where things
are are at are located so just keep that
in
mind um so we wanted to accomplish that
task we wanted to be able to say okay if
I give it a molecule and I want to
optimize um some specific property how
it binds to a protein maybe maybe to
maybe some measure of toxicity um so how
will you do that um there's a variety of
techniques that this can be um
accomplished one of them is called
control Generation Um you basically form
a mini
optimization in this in this model's
Laten space so you predict I don't know
10 15 molecules and then you you predict
this property it's called an oracle
right but you predict the property or
properties that you want and then you
sort of make a fake the pseudo gradient
and then you take a step and then you do
and you take some of the best performing
molecules you sample again you calculate
gradient you take enough step so it's
very imprecise it's very noisy um but
that is that's one way of doing it so
this is a very simple method for doing
this task um and the technique that I'm
describing to you is called cmaes um
there are more sophisticated things you
can do um sometimes reinforcement
learning is used as well to generate a
small agent that knows how to manipulate
or how to maneuver in the l
space um the numbers here aren't
important um point being we were able to
train a model um that has four oracles
two of them were molecular properties
and two of them were buying to a Target
um and we calculated some metrics um
this is uh commonly used and we took uh
sort of the basis for this uh method
from a paper um success so how many of
the molecules meet desired criteria at
the end of the optimization um how many
of them are novel and then how diverse
are they um across the populations that
we sampled um we didn't yet we haven't
yet reached state-of-the-art um but I
will say many of these models on the top
were trained trained with some notion of
molecular properties or they were
trained for this very specific control
generation task mman was not so the fact
that it's competitive at least for
success in diversity is is very
encouraging um you know we continue to
try to improve it but I think it's also
nice for people to see that no you don't
just automatically get state-of-the-art
off off the bat it's it's a bit of work
so um it's a very well performed model
there's always opportunities to improve
it um so I think this is a nice example
too of our team I'm really proud of it
because um it's something we took from
research development into productize it
um it is going to be released in the
inference service um very soon and
there's some control generation tasks so
exactly the the process that I just
described to you um you can do in the
inference service um we're working on
productizing this model in the framework
so that users can train it develop their
own make their own changes to it um so
you know I'm really kind of proud like
the very first sort of your first your
team's first paper this is our first
paper so I'm very excited about
that um all right I will conclude um
with sort of how I got here um some
lessons learned along the way um so this
will be more of a a trip down memory
lane I guess if you will um about 10
years ago 11 10 10 11 years ago um I was
finishing my finishing of my postto at
Columbia um I'm trained as a structural
biologist
um I specialized in a technique called
NMR spectroscopy I studied proteins
those three dimensional things I've been
telling you about um I studied them that
was I loved it um I I still to this day
love science but I was thinking about
what I wanted to do next and there was
this thing called data science um
happening and I didn't really know a lot
about it but I heard of it I heard of
machine learning that was kind of
interesting what what do you what do you
what do you do with machine learning
what is that um and then about about
right about the time I was thinking
about what I wanted to do um something
happened um a little deep Learning
Network called Alex net won the imet won
the image net challenge in 2012 and it
didn't just win it walloped it it
dominated and so this is important
because I'll bring this up again but I
was like this is interesting I think
this is probably going to
impact pretty much every industry at
some point some way in the future maybe
I should learn a little bit about this
so I started studying it I started
following a bunch of data scientists and
machine learning practitioners uh
researchers on Twitter um I sort of I I
took the scientific method I guess I was
I started studying what they talk about
what they do um trying to understand it
um and I guess you know one lesson I
would say is you know don't get so
caught up in what you're doing now that
you you miss the bigger picture um
certainly I've not always caught that in
my in my life um but I'm very happy that
I sort of realized that I should maybe
learn a little bit about this um it's
why I'm here now doing what I'm doing so
when I needed to learn more about it um
that was the time that things like
Corsair really became popular um they
were pretty new you could take online
courses so I started teaching myself
machine learning um there's some great
older Andrew in courses on there I took
all that stuff Jeffrey hinton's course
yep took that um so I started teaching
myself machine
learning um I also went to Pi data so
again when I was here in 2013 I was
really dipping my toes into data science
into the machine learning and trying to
understand what this was if I make this
jump in my career what does it mean I'm
not really
sure um and then Lauren actually
reminded me um we we ended up going to a
conference another conference together
and somehow some Nvidia was a sponsor
and they recruited me so I sort of have
ended up that's how I ended up in Nvidia
um where I've been for most of my career
since I left science so kind of a
wild maybe twisty tury um path but
that's how I ended up there um and then
something happened and I should say
going into data science my chief concern
was that I wanted to still do science
and data science machine learning on
science wasn't really a thing back in
that time 2013 you know it was brand new
we only really knew how to do it with
images and that was really hard so I
didn't really know if this was going to
be possible
but I tried um and in
2018 um there was truly a watershed
moment in in scientific discovery Deep
Mind developed a model that they called
alol and it took protein sequences and
predicted the structure and I will be
the first to tell you that it's not
perfect there are there are lots of
opportunities for improvement but it was
amazing and they entered a protein
folding competition so the sort of the
image net of protein folding and they
dominated it they didn't just just win
one or two categories they won every
single one and they have continued to
win it every year variations of of alha
gold improved of course incrementally
they've won it every year since then so
that changed a lot of
things at this point it became very easy
to to do uh to do science and machine
learning but um it was it was quite a it
was quite an amazing time um so you know
yeah I I don't even know what to what
else to say it's such an amazing moment
for someone who spent so many years at
her career studying this so it's pretty
cool um then something else happened not
such an exciting thing um Ai and the RS
for Co vaccines um you know we had we
had a pandemic and that further um
encourag leadership at Nvidia that it
was time to start developing some sort
of toolkit for drug Discovery so my
little team that I you know that I'm now
also a part of was really born during
the pandemic um fall of 2020 we started
working on this
so um certainly Co vaccines um there
were there were many points at which um
artificial intelligence helped
accelerated that accelerate that but it
made it very clear that we needed to
accelerate um the way we do science and
so that's um that that's how we were
born um and this is our first effort it
is not really involving any machine
learning or any certainly any deep
learning um we we made a an interface
that would take take Smiles small
molecules um do PCA and then do um like
te on them to visualize them and it was
it was really something pretty basic it
was myself and one other engineer so you
we didn't have a lot of resources to
train deep learning models um but this
was something we could develop it was
multi-gpu um multi-node in some cases um
so we showed that we could ship
something I think the other lesson there
is um we had something that didn't
depend on machine learning so we could
we could ship this product um we could
produce something that was real and it
was the foundation though for our future
machine learning efforts because it was
a really nice way for us to visualize
the molecules that were being generated
by some of these models I just told you
about um so then this is this is a
colleague slide but few more years past
Alpha fold happens um you know
variations of alpha fold and it has led
to a revolution in the field and the
joke is
yes all of these slides are outdated and
and they actually probably are so every
every day there's multiple pre-prints
and papers um that are phenomenal uh by
by
researchers um here's one I thought
we're we're near to the end of the talk
I thought you would enjoy some agre of
eye candy um this is a model called
chroma um developed by generate
biomedicine researches that generate
biom medicines which is a startup um
it's a diffusion model um you can give
it characteristics and it will Design
any kind of a protein for you so you can
see increasingly large proteins they
have these beautiful Symmetry and
structures to them um you can also have
it designed letters of the alphabet
for I don't even know what the I don't I
know what these do spell out your name
and amino acids um anyway it's pretty
amazing I think um you know these not
all of these proteins have been
experimentally validated but they are in
the process of doing that so I I think
it's exciting and phenomenal to to know
what the future will hold for us um but
you know we can start proteins
themselves are Therapeutics we can
design design our own Therapeutics we
can have better targeting of drugs
diseases that maybe we couldn't care I
don't I think it's it's
amazing um I think so you know that was
really how we started working on deep
learning models at scale
um the the sort of numbers here aren't
that important but we're you know start
we've started to work on riskier and
riskier your projects as the team has
grown um this is a model we that's
published by a team at at meta um it's
called esm it's evolutionary scale
modeling um it is we're working on
accelerating a 3 billion version of it
and then so three billion parameters and
then we're working on accelerating even
bigger versions of it so um we're also
developing improvements on it um so
there'll be more to come in this space
but I think um you know as I just said
doing lower risk things that you can
ship is important I think it's also
knowing the right time to do things that
are higher risk because starting to
develop deep learning models at scale
was what really led us to um to grow as
a team and to the rise of this project
um at least certainly within um idia and
so the that will bring me to my last
slide um so our team is we started as
two engineers and I think even in 2021
we were we were two Engineers um so in
less than two years are now over 30 and
and still growing and much like the joke
about protein design the list of the
team will probably be outdated on a
daily
basis um and so I became a manager and
discovered that as hard as deep learning
is people problems are
hard um and really that's it um so hope
I've given you a whirlwind tour of of
things that I think about these days um
our our product by oimo it's inference
service um and then the training
framework some of the research that we
do as a team that we hope try to
productize um in this case MIM um from a
a chem informatics language model um I
think as far as life advice goes I don't
I don't know that I'm qualified for that
but whatever career careers are long
compared to the machine learning
development cycle so really find
Opportunities to capitalize on that um
as often as you can if you are in this
space and you're interested um um you
can apply for Early Access for the
inference service um and the framework
General access is coming next week
fingers crossed um this is our team this
is up to date but in a couple weeks I
think it'll won't be
anymore it's worth wild to see that how
we've grown um and thank you so I will
be at the fireside chat later if you
have questions please come and that's
how you can get a hold of
[Music]
me
[Applause]